so as you guys may or may not know you
know the person that produces all my
videos or as of late anyway so just girl
Danielle don't follow her at all she's a
[ __ ] loser
if you learn how to target my favorite
favorite song is for like sexual dancing
Ciara body party I [ __ ] love that
song dude every doubt that I think the
one thing I love doing tour is creeping
her out that's like my [ __ ] she's like a
little sister that I never [ __ ] wanted
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I love holding babies that sounds a lot
creep it actually shifted where do I
keep up
I'll see baby stare into your soul
babies are so dope because I feel like
when you hold a child and they love you
back it kind of brings this energy back
guard you ever smells the top of a
baby's head it's crazy it's like taking
a Red Bull you just gotta say oh my oh
my oh oh my this time my disturb Oh
[Music]
baby little baby summit this is how baby
fever starts we have no idea I've been
having their kid usually comes to my
place sometimes in the morning cuz she
does my personal assistants tough I
actually hide her to help me out with
all that huh but one thing that she
really loves it babies you know she has
her kid Isaac and I think she always has
this yearning to be around like that
baby that stage in their life where
they're super young and it really
depends on you she really misses that so
the moment she saw KS she's like I know
I'm beautiful bro you incredibly if you
guys don't know what baby fever is is
basically when a woman reaches a certain
age and every time she see the child her
[ __ ] ovaries start to activate like
those little dragon balls when they
clearly gather together and they bring
up the dress maybe's have this
interesting effect on adults especially
males like you could be the biggest dog
on earth but the moment you see a cute
baby it goes immediately away he's sup
cuz would you go in baby comes by
[Laughter]
I know
babies are the biggest [ __ ] liars on
earth they have the amazing ability to
just cry on the spot even though it's
away but they are wide you mean clearing
[Laughter]
my Asian families the great thing about
having your grandparents is that no
matter how much they [ __ ] up with you
they can't wait to take care of your
children to make sure they didn't repeat
the fuck-ups oh good job Asian parents
they just kind of wait for you to have a
kid like once you reach like the age
like 20-something
they always ask what do you have a kid
what do you have a kid so what we always
have a forever babysitter that's not
gonna cost us money and if we ever need
to go on vacation go out of town if
we're busy with something or we just
need one-on-one times you know with our
spouse all we gotta do is throw our baby
away to the grandparents it's
fashionable you got some Kevin oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah oh good I got boobies
I got enough boobies for the whole world
I'm the perfect of malim between a woman
in a man I know I like babies babies
[Music]